monsieur on peut en avant une tasse mais
aussi à je regrette mon cher monsieur
parce qu'en général le thé préparé pour
nos agents qui circulent toute la
journée
et comme il fait très froid eh bien ils
sont très contents d'en avoir une tasse
de thé pour les réchauffer au sein du
team et il a une drôle d'odeur s'était
inquiété en général en hiver il ya
toujours un peu d'auteurs il faut mettre
un petit rhume sans cela il y aurait pas
de goût et comme il fait bien froid et
ben il faut avoir l'attention de m
quelque chose dedans et combien depuis
combien de temps votre métier en fait
depuis ça fait ma cinquième année que je
fais ce métier était comme hiver n'est
ce pas et en général
enfin l'hiver dernier on en a pas eu
c'est beaucoup mais l'hiver 63 à 64 ont
analysé environs du mois de janvier
jusqu'au mois de février on en a eu ses
700 litres
comment vous faites votre distribution
alors notre distribution premièrement
elle se fait de cette manière le thé
proprement dit il est préparé et on peut
dire en été il ya et les biens citronnée
en hiver on est un peu drôle parce quand
j'écris dans quelles proportions
ah mais ça évidemment il faut bien c'est
à ce crétin secret parce qu'il joue pas
c'est un secret professionnel mais pas
pour moi non seulement mais aussi pour
le restaurateur pour la préparation et
la finition du thé monsieur vous êtes
chauffeurs d'autobus qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette chose là
en fait cette chose c'est très bien mais
ça passe ça vous savez ça nous plaît ça
nous réchauffer en hiver surtout si
après quelques heures de service parce
qu'on est bien contente d'avoir quelque
chose telle chose de le vendre comme
jeudi avec ce froid là qui se fait
actuellement en dessous 15 16 17 18 juin
comptant est ce que vous trouvez qu'ils
aient assez de rome dans le thé où il a
arrêté de le rendre est vrai très fameux
il est très fameux temps généralisé mans
toujours une deuxième place parce
qu'elle est très très très fameux et je
félicite les préparateurs parce que ça
nous plaît
alors monsieur qu'est ce que vous en
pensez quel goût et il
il manque un peu de rhum
[Musique]